Once Upon a
Time no actually it's happening right
now you see these are evil times in our
Medieval Times from his Dark Tower the
wicked sorcerer elmenus the pyromancer
is plotting a most Sinister ofs against
our beloved
King is by Royal Decree the king now
calls Upon a Hero to embark on a quest
most perilous to capture the villain
once and for
all from the wreaking swamps to The
Dungeons of dragon Hall your path will
surely be besieged with
dangers there'll be trolls there'll be
Ogar there'll be
dragons
fairies but
mostly the angel in your question will
surely be terrible frightening nasty
creatures with me
d